وغيرها من الدبابات وفي الطريق الى
اوكرانيا اسلحه متطوره اخرى النصر قد لا
يكون هو المقصود بكل المساعدات العسكريه
تلك
الدبلوماسيه جائز اهدف يختبئ خلف تلك
الاسلحه الحديثه
جذب الرئيس الروسي الى طاوله المفاوضات
وكسر حاله الجمود
التصعيد لخفض التصعيد بحسب
امريكا وحلفائها يعملون على تحديث
استراتيجياتهم في حرب اوكرانيا بثلاث طرق
تحديد اهداف الحرب ومنها استعاده بعض
الاراضي من قبضه روسيا ارسال اسلحه اكثر
تطورا يمكنها اختراق الدفاعات الروسيه
استهداف بعض الاماكن الاستراتيجيه المهمه
لدى روسيا باستخدام الاسلحه بعيده المدى
ومنها شبه جزيره القرم افضل طريقه اجبار
الرئيس الروسي على التفاوض بجديه ان شعر
بفقدان الجزيره المهمه
هو مسح الرئيس الامريكي والحلفاء مساعده
اوكرانيا على زياده الضغط على القوه
الروسيه وتحويل مسار الحرب اكثر لصالحها
كطريق اكثر للمفاوضات بعد انتهاء المرحله
التاليه من القتال
عصام عبد السلام العربيه